What's up guys!
We are Pongfinity.
Today we are back with another episode of "Challenge Pongfinity".
If you are wondering
what happened to Miikka's hair
Go check out the 500k special video!
But now to
the challenges!
Okay, so I have shaved my hair off
specifically to find out if I can play with it.
Pretty good head!
Drop shot!
Good neck exercise!
With my eye!
Nice!
My head serve.
I haven't received any of those serves yet!
Maybe I will start using this serve!
or maybe not...
Was it around the net?
Yes, it was.
You actually won the point.
Alright, now let's try to play off the wall.
I feel like we are playing squash or
something.
Alright, this is an interesting idea.
Let's fill the cups.
Emil why are we even filling the cups?
I have no idea.
Fill mine.
Okay.
I will actually put some more to you.
No, no, no!
This was a terrible idea.
Okay, let's leave the water out!
No more water!
It looks like we are going to a very strange birthday party.
Your face!
It was so close!
Your ball was in the way!
I think that we had some pretty
good challenges today!
Make sure you keep leaving those comments and
ideas in the comment-section below!
Remember to subscribe here and watch
the previous episodes there!
Until next time